hi everyone it's alana ochoa lonzard
welcome to my channel um i have been
playing wasteland 2 over the past couple
of weeks i've put in i think about 25
hours so far but i decided that i want
to start over the game and put more
effort into the character customization
and i'm currently waiting for forza
horizon 2 to download on my xbox one
it's taken like over 24 hours
thanks tony abbott um so i thought that
while it's just finishing up the
installation that i would just
show you guys the wasteland to character
customization uh stuff
so the reason i'm actually restarting
is because i want to see
how different it is with a different set
of group with different skills and also
um there are a lot of decisions that you
make even really small decisions and i
want to change the decisions that i make
on a second place to see how much it
actually affects
what happens so
character customization
pre-made characters already have all the
attributes skills and appearance
assigned but you just met them
so that's where they go up now you have
four to select
these ones are all pre-made ones with
different skills already but obviously
you can go custom so we'll do slick
because i used him before and really
appreciated him so
combat skills
attributes alright so up here your
attribute points these are like any kind
of standard rpg ish
um yeah so coordination gives you
more action points is probably it says
just there so you guys can read it
number of action points and bonus rage
hit chance luck i didn't have any lucky
characters before um
so i think maybe i will make a lucky one
now just to see how big the difference
actually is if i make a lucky one
which i think would be interesting
awareness
strength just kind of lets you carry
extra stuff which is super important
so charisma is the most important thing
for this guy who i'm going to have as
the same thing he did last time which is
basically the one who talks to the
people and makes the outcomeses
so we're going to give you an extra
charisma point
the rest should be fine keep water up
keep kiss us up keep smart ass up
bladed weapons
there you go um i think we'll give you
handguns
so this all seems fine probably don't
need any of this stuff
i mean you obviously need touch to
repair so
you know
i actually i don't i don't even
um smartass kiss us and bada obviously
all of those will influence
how you talk to people and
what you can say to them kind of thing
um
so then we jump over here we have slick
look at him when a handsome [ __ ]
um religion none let's make you
a buddhist
just because smokes
none you're not a smoker you're a
buddhist you can't be a smoker yeah
we'll keep you american an american
non-smoking buddhist
and i'm pretty happy with the way he
looks you can change everything but
we'll do that with another character i
think
um so next was going to be
combat medic
pills
also looks
super cool
kind of maybe won't change hurry though
so
coordination
i'm pretty happy with all that i guess
maybe your intelligence could be a
little bit higher but i don't know what
to get rid of
um
this is the combat medic right i think
we need better speed for you you don't
need the charisma
put your speed up
alrighty
handguns as well yeah that's fine field
medic and surgeon perfect
all right not liking the way you look
though love so let's change that
yeah those are cool
now you can change your pack
i don't really care what your pack looks
like yeah that's cool
i feel like that looks pretty good you
could change your head i guess
but i kind of like those levels of weird
no we're gonna keep it we're gonna keep
you weird
nice
um
let's go
asian
religion
let's make you a christian a christian
asian and an american buddhist
that's what's up
all right what else do we want here i
feel like a hunter wouldn't be too no
okay let's make a custom guy
um this one is going to be like a
a someone for combats for the combats
so let's give you more strength
maybe some more intelligence
i don't know
no you should be fine
i'll give you another coordination let's
give you some luck as well because i
hadn't done any of those last time so
another strength one there
speed's probably pretty handy for
youtube
you don't need the intelligence you
don't need the charisma
um
coordination
strength
speed coordination
there we go that should do us fine
general skills we want you to have brute
force sounds about right
and you probably don't need anything
more than that really weapon smithing
maybe
yeah sure okay
um
let's give you some machine guns maybe
some machine guns or assault rifles
let's go assault raffles
and
yeah i think that's kind of fine maybe
i'll give you shotguns as well or
something
or blunt weapons that sounds good to me
blonde weapons all right
donsky's
now what are we going to make you male
or female i guess i'll just stay with
female
gotta change that
make you look
cuter
i like that i like face paint that's
cool
um some kind of interesting head garb
oh nice
uh let's do
native american then
and
indigenous nice one
um name
i don't know what do you look like your
name would be i want to give you like a
wastelandi name
so how about like
wow i don't know i don't know what a
waste landy name would be
so i'm i i don't
this is really tough let's let's
continue making you and then see what
you like pop out as
shall we
sounds like a good idea to me
that's so hipster at your lungs shirt
and
tie what a hipster flaming hipster
that looks cool
i'm already pretty up with those pants i
think
it looks pretty cool skin tone
that looks good size
yeah let's make you huge oh no let's
make it tiny so it's all cute
so you're like
the murderer on the team but you're all
tiny
and then we change the sky make it make
it nice and blue for your love
um and then take snapshots
there you go you still don't have a name
rough stuff rough stuff uh let's make
you a smoker as well
you can smoke nico pops
and how about your name be
i'm trying to combine nico pop
nip up
there you go
named after your dirty dirty addiction
um so we have you what else do we need
um
tacky would probably be pretty handy
so let's go hex here
okay
yeah that all seems pretty fair probably
don't need you to be
very fast but
um all right
perception
hmm i'll just give you one of those
maybe i would love to have an animal
whisperer
let's just
like
it's probably not necessary but i really
want it just like i want a toaster
repair
happy with all this though i think um if
we give you mechanical repair
just one there
yep
and
man this is this is super rough i would
really like to have a toaster repair
and
what new but no alas
we shall not all right that should be
all good
hex you are going to be
a
muslim
russian
uh i don't like your pants
get y'all some new pants
there you go
skin tone
that one go white as a toilet
um
yeah cool all good
so wasteland 2 so far is my game of the
year i really love it um and this is
obviously just a really small glimpse of
it i'm not going to do a let's play of
this one um
it's the kind of game that i don't want
to i think it's something that i really
want to invest in by myself so
so i'm not going to do any more than
this but this is character customization
um and a little insight to what the game
is about i guess uh post-apocalyptic
fanciness is my general spiel so i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and have
learned how the character customization
works and i will see you guys next time